[Music]
look where we are
[Music]
icarus
evening ladies
watch out
who is it
[Music]
five years ago thanos erased half of the
population of the universe but the
people of this planet brought everyone
back with a snap of a finger
the sudden return of the population
provided the necessary energy for the
emergence to begin
how long do we have
seven days
we're eternals
[Music]
we came here 7000 years ago
to protect humans from the deviants
why didn't you guys help fight thanos or
any war all the other terrible things
throughout history
[Music]
we were instructed not to interfere in
any human conflicts and estevians are
involved
by who
[Music]
we need to find the others
i haven't seen some of them for
centuries
hi
hello
this is what the end of the world looks
like
at least we have front row seats
you know what's never saved the planet
you're sarcasm
[Music]
[Applause]
we have loved these people since the day
we arrived
when you love something
you protect it
[Applause]
you can't protect
of
[Music]
i bet you've them the perfect safe house
what's this even made of vibranium
fall collection
ikea
[Music]
you